so so far so good is that okay what I
want to now do is I want to move forward
and maybe you could actually help me by
drawing this diagram
I want to rehearse for you this idea of
proving if we come from this polar
formula which is the definition right
the polar formula is is slightly a pain
because you've got to work out the angle
like you've got to know what Theta is
and normally when you get given a vector
um you are rather two vectors you know
that x's and y's and Z's right you know
them in component form or in common form
same deal right
so you don't normally know what theater
is it takes some effort to work out what
theater is and so what we want is an
alternative way to express the dot
product that is independent of theta
okay now maybe if it's you know
reasonably recent you might have the
proof of this fresh in your mind so I'm
not going to go through this in
um minute detail but we're going to show
how in fact this result still works in
three dimensions just like it worked in
two Dimensions okay
so um for starters right you have a look
at this triangle here formed between the
origin and then I've got b and a
positioned in arbitrary places it really
doesn't matter where they are okay now
I want to get some expression for this
that has
um that will allow me to eliminate cos
Theta okay so you can see I've drawn
this triangle because once I've got a
triangle I can use the cosine rule on
this triangle does that make sense the
cosine rule allows me to find an
expression for cos Theta that doesn't
have any thetas in it like the cosine
rule if you guys remember it actually
help me help me recite it right because
of we normally say like COS of capital c
um I wonder if you remember it's a
fraction right do you remember this
what's on the top
I know it not with because save like as
the as the subject
like
this oh okay yeah that's totally fine
let's just go from there because um if
you remember that it's the same formula
right it only takes a bit of
rearrangement so um help me out what's
the bit on the right hand side
yeah
minus
Theta okay fantastic or or in this case
because I've got A's B's and C's I'll
just put capital c um exactly right and
by the way just for what it's worth this
is also the way I remember it like I
remember uh the cosine rule as
Pythagoras Theorem on steroids okay
that's the way I think about it however
you can see what I could do is
to the c squared and the the 2A B cos C
you can see I can basically add and
subtract them from both sides of the
equation and then divide through so what
you'll end up getting is a squared plus
b squared that's that's still there I
have to subtract the c squared from both
sides and then you divide through by
that constant coefficient that gives you
2A B right
so can you see here if I use the cosine
rule on this triangle that we've just
drawn with the vectors on it right I can
get an expression for cos well like you
said Theta right that doesn't have any
feeders in it right this thing on the
right hand side it's independent of
theta it's just in terms of the length
of the sides okay so just to remind you
right
if we I want to know what all three
sides are so I can say look
um the length of that purple Vector
there is just the the magnitude of B
right is that okay like so and then I
can say the length of the green side is
just the magnitude of vector a
like so
all I need is an expression for the
magnitude of that third side a b and I
can do that using Vector thinking right
hopefully you recognize you don't have
to draw this by the way but um it's just
a reminder if I reversed uh that b
Vector right then it's the same as
saying okay I can go from B
um to O and then from o to a I'm just
going to string those vectors together
you might remember the fancy word
concatenate
so that's minus B plus a which I have
written up the top here does that make
sense and so really what I've got here
returning to my original triangle OAB
this length over here is just the
magnitude of a minus B are you guys
content with that
yeah
okay fantastic so what I'm going to now
do is you can see I've got some working
already here please don't fret too much
if I uh go too quickly through this I'm
just looking at the time for you to
write don't don't stress too much about
writing this right
um because I will give you these notes
afterwards just like I have with other
nodes however if it does help you to
write then then keep up with me okay
so what I'm going to do is I'm first
just going to State you know how um just
like you said Sean uh this was the
cosine rule stated in that Pythagoras
form uh that you stated up here right
this one here in fact you know what let
me just drag that down here
here it is
this is the cosine rule but for this
triangle does that make sense so I've
got my a b which I've got up the top
here so that's a b just along there
um and then I've got OA squared
um OB squared and and so on is that okay
so far so good
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
replace those lengths with Vector
notation versions of those links right
so you can see this is what I'm calling
a b in Vector notation
I've got the OA and the OB you can see
I've highlighted this so I'm going to
write it basically like so is this all
right
okay now here is the part where you're
going to see why I'm like okay don't
worry too much about right ears because
it gets very long very quickly okay
let's have a think about the left hand
side right the left hand side is just
the distance from A to B the distance
from A to B right so this is just the
Pythagoras it's a very very long
Pythagoras formula do you remember that
except it is it is squared oops sorry I
didn't mean to erase that it is squared
so normally you know you'd see that big
long square root but because I'm
squaring it that thing's gone okay so do
you remember this is basically what we
get you take the difference of the X's
difference of the Y's difference of the
Z's then you square everything okay so
all of this all of this
came from just uh that term so far so
good
okay on the right hand side what I want
to do is again there's going to be some
long notation here right so to to
highlight what's going on here I'm going
to separate out I'll make this Vector
here I'll highlight that as blue
actually you know what that's a bit
silly I've already got a color for that
I've got like green or something right
so this is
this is this Factor up here okay that's
going to be my green one I've got um a
purple one I've written uh that b Vector
in purple so this is what I'm going to
follow with here so I want you to
remember What's the magnitude of the
vector just from the origin that's what
it is right hopefully you can see it
ends up quite long this is what you
recall is that okay you just do the X's
the Y's and Z's you square them then and
that was this one here
so this is B
and then this other one is is from a
are you right there I know it's a lot of
algebra but uh hopefully we're following
along so far so good
okay now at this point here even though
it's long and awkward there's actually a
lot of canceling that I can do if you
arrange it a bit more easily now
normally we frown upon having equations
written on multiple lines but you can
see how long this thing is and actually
it's easier if I write this across a few
lines so you can see the structure right
so what I've got here is I've squared
everything out can you see that so say
for example if you just focus on uh this
this first one over here
this year can you see that's my first
line x squared minus 2 x X Plus x
squared again right so far so good you
can see the subscripts okay
um so each line is it's the x's and then
the Y's and then the Z's okay
over on the right hand side
um I actually haven't done anything
different I've just arranged it so that
you can see these terms here
um separate from these terms here
all right can you guys tell me how am I
going to go about canceling this what am
I going to do
you can cancel the squares because yeah
very good so you can see um the x y z
for the A's right that's that's all of
these terms in here and then the XYZ for
the B's that's all these terms here so
just when we Square everything out
normally expanding things makes things
an awful mess but in this case it's fine
so they're all going to cancel in fact
I'm going to say like that cancels with
that does that make sense and then that
cancels with that
so all we get left with is uh these
minus two x's minus two y's and so on we
just get left with these terms in the
middle
and you can see all of them if I just
write them out across ways you can see
there's going to be all of that comes
from that's a terrible brace sorry let's
try and make that bit better there we go
can you see where I've gotten that from
what can you now see obviously that I
can divide through by on both sides
yeah there's a common factor of negative
two so when there I am but once you
notice like if you divide through by
negative two on the right hand side you
just end up with this which is our
definition of the dot product so that's
why I've just replaced it with that on
the right hand side so are you content
can you see how I end up with this even
though we Define it as like it's to do
with the angles I have this version of
it
um which is to do with all of the
components okay
so how are you going do were you able to
follow that algebra do you have any
questions about that so far
okay fantastic so here's my favorite bit
okay and you'll actually weirdly you'll
need to sit together for this one so I
don't know who wants to move but one of
you need to move and um okay Sean you're
moving Ryan do you have two pens on your
desk there
okay so I need you to have two pens
and um the the part about this that is
wild for me is right just go back to our
first comment here we said ah what's a
guess for why or how rather we can
extend the um
two-dimensional formula for the dot
product into three dimensions right and
you
um very accurately said this you're like
oh with component form it's really easy
you had x's and Y's just just addeds
right and for me it was always really
sensible to do that but then I thought
well but hold on this polar formula we
just we just derived in three dimensions
and it's exactly the same in three
dimensions as it is in two Dimensions
right I want to prove to you why that
actually makes sense that even though
the three-dimensional formula in
component form changes the the the the
three-dimensional formula in polar form
does not change okay so here's what I
need you to do in fact I need two pens
as well
um here's what I want you to do the
first one we're not going to do you can
actually do this independently I want
you to take your two pens and I want you
to imagine them as two vectors okay so
um take the lids off so you can see I've
got one facing This Thread one facing
that way okay now obviously if you guys
could just take the two pens just put
them on the table for a minute right
lay them on the table and you can see no
matter where you put them if you put
them like pretty randomly right
obviously your two vectors they sit on
the same plane which is the table right
so the name for this is they are
coplanar it's just like collinear
collinear means two or three points on
the same line coplanar means you got two
vectors they're on the same plane okay
now here's the part where I need two of
you okay
um I want one of you to hold up the two
pens take the two pens and then I want
the other of you to hold up your book
your book is going to be the plan okay
so Sean you've got the book all right
now yep okay now Ryan what I want you to
do is in in midair in three-dimensional
space in front of your face okay
um just keep the Tails together but I
want you to face the two vectors in any
random direction that you like okay in
arbitrary directions
um so just face them anywhere and now
Sean your challenges after Ryan's picked
two directions right I want you to place
your book
on the plane
that is shared by those two vectors can
you go ahead and do that find find a
plane somewhere so you're gonna need to
move your book so that it is like
matched up against those two pens have
you found a spot yeah
yeah okay that wasn't too difficult
right now Ryan it looks to me like you
made that really easy for Sean okay I
want you to try again I want you to make
it somewhere weirder and wackier right
place the two vectors in two other
different directions
any way you like
yeah
yeah try try and like get off off plane
right
okay and now wherever you end up are you
starting to realize Sean go ahead take
your book again
wherever Ryan places his two vectors
yeah very good you have to put a
different orientation but you can still
find a plant you can put your stuff down
now you can always find a plane in other
words a two-dimensional surface that
three-dimensional vectors will always
sit on does that make sense no matter
where your three dimensions are you can
actually still find a two-dimensional
point of view that will work to consider
you can see this on the screen to
consider your three-dimensional vectors
as two-dimensional things like there's a
two-dimensional angle between them so
that's why the polar formula in three
dimensions it's the same as the polar
formula in two Dimensions does that make
sense
okay um I hope that clicked for you it
was a bit wild for me and as you can
imagine based on what you physically did
uh it's really hard for textbooks to
convey that or for pictures to convey
that because they're in two Dimensions
right you've got to do it in three